WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU, SANDRA.
>> I THINK HE’S ABSENTLY CORRECT
ABOUT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
I THINK IF YOU TOOK PRESIDENT XI
OF CHINA AND TURNED HIM UPSIDE
DOWN AND SHOOK HIM, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WOULD FALL
OUT OF HIS POCKETS.
AND THAT’S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
>> Ed: LOUISIANA KENNETT,
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY WITH HIS
UNIQUE STYLE THERE CRITICIZING
AS THE WHITE HOUSE OR INSTA CUT
OFF AID TO THE AGENCY.
LET’S BRING IN SENATOR COTTON.
>> GOOD MORNING.
SPEAK >> Ed: I NOTICED THAT
YOUR COLLEAGUE HAS A UNIQUE
STYLE AND MANNER OF SPEAKING BUT
BOTTOM LINE, I SEE YOUR SMILE
THERE, IS THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND APOLOGIST FOR
CHINA?
>> UNFORTUNATELY THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS IN THE
POCKET OF CHINA, ESPECIALLY
TEDROS, WHEN HE WAS INVESTING DB
THEM ACTIVELY THERE, HE HAS A
WELL-KNOWN AND FRANKLY WELL
DESERVED REPUTATION FOR
CORRUPTION THAT’S GONE FROM
ETHIOPIA TO THE W.H.O.
THAT’S WHY THE PRESIDENT WAS
RIGHT THAT WE NEED TO CONDITION
FUTURE FUNDING.
IN THE ADMISSION OF TAIWAN, AT
LEAST ON AS AN OBSERVER TO THE
W.H.O.
IF WE CAN’T DO THAT THEN WE HAVE
TO ESTABLISH OUR OWN
ORGANIZATION AND INVITE MEMBERS
OF THE CIVILIZED WORLD TO JOIN
US USING AMERICAN STANDARDS OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Ed: SENATOR, YOU JUST
MENTIONED THE DIRECTOR OF THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
HE FIRED BACK YESTERDAY AND HAD
A WARNING FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
MAY BE FOR YOU AS WELL.
>> IF YOU DON’T WANT MANY MORE
BODY BAGS, THEN YOU REFRAIN FROM
POLITICIZING IT.
MY SHORT MESSAGES, PLEASE
QUARANTINE POLITICIZING COVID.
>> Ed: HE SAID IF YOU KEEP
THIS UP THERE WILL BE MORE BODY
BAGS.
IS THERE A POINT REGARDLESS OF
BACK AND FORTH OF CUTTING OFF
FUNDING TO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THAT’S TRYING TO
PREVENT FUTURE PANDEMICS I COULD
BACKFIRE ON US?
>> I’M DISGUSTED BY THAT KIND OF
THREAT FROM SOME TWO BIT
THIRD-RATE DEMOCRAT.
THAT’S WHY TEDROS NEEDS TO BE
FIRED AND INVESTIGATED SO WE CAN
FIND OUT HOW DEEPLY IN CHINA’S
POCKET HE IS.
IN JANUARY I WAS REPORTED,
POINTING OUT THAT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WAS MORE
INTERESTED IN THE POLITICALLY
CORRECT APPEASEMENT OF CHINA
CALLING THE VIRUS SOMETHING
BESIDES WHAT IT SHOULD BE CALLED
WHICH IS THE CHINA VIRUS OR THE
WUHAN CORONAVIRUS, THEN IT WAS
TRYING TO GET TO THE TRUTH.
IT ACCEPTED CHINA’S LUDICROUSLY
FALSE CLAIMS THAT THERE WAS NO
HUMAN TO HUMAN CONTACT IN THE
EARLY DAYS OF THIS VIRUS.
IT REFUSED TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE LEARNINGS THAT WE HAD FROM
TAIWAN BECAUSE TAIWAN IS NOT
VIEWED BY BEIJING AS A COUNTRY.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT HAVE TO CHANGE AT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION AND
DR. TEDROS’ TWO BIT ACCUSATIONS
AND THREATS ARE NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THOSE FACTS.
>> Ed: YOU CERTAINLY HAD A
CHANCE TO RESPOND THERE, LET’S
BRING IT BACK HOME AND TO WHAT’S
HAPPENING WITH VERY HARD HIT
FAMILIES IN YOUR STATE AND OTHER
STATES.
WE SEEN UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
GOING UP AND YOU AND OTHERS ON
THE HILL HAVE BEEN TRYING TO DO
A LOT WITH THE STIMULUS.
THERE’S A QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS ARE GETTING
TO THE PEOPLE THAT NEED IT AND
SENATOR McCONNELL WILL TALK ON
THE NEXT HOUR.
IN THE MEANTIME YOU AND
DOUG JONES ARE SAYING WE HAVE TO
GET THE MONEY FASTER TO
INDIVIDUALS.
YOU SAID WE ENCOURAGE THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT TO TARGET A
GROUP OF AMERICANS, THE OPTION
OF GETTING THEIR PAYMENT ON
DIRECT EXPRESS DEBIT CARDS.
TALK ABOUT THE FOCUS ON THIS AND
IS VERY CONCERNED THAT THE MONEY
IS SIMPLY NOT GETTING THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT QUICKLY ENOUGH?
>> THE SMALL BUSINESS LOANS,
THERE’S HONESTLY BEEN SOME
BUREAUCRATIC SNAFUS AND WE ARE
WORKING OUT THE KINKS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
MY TEAM AND I HAVE BEEN ON THE
PHONE ALMOST CONSTANTLY WITH THE
BANKERS IN ARKANSAS, THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TREASURY.
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL PAYMENTS,
MANY PEOPLE WILL BE GETTING
THOSE DIRECT DEPOSITS STARTING
NEXT WEEK.
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO DON’T HAVE DIRECT
DEPOSIT SET UP AND THEY MAY NOT
EVEN HAVE BANK ACCOUNTS.
RATHER THAN SEND PAPER CHECKS
WHICH ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUD
AND REQUIRE YOU TO GET OUT OF
YOUR HOUSE AND GO TO THE BANK
AND CASH THE CHECK, WE WANT THE
TREASURY TO EXPLORE THE
POSSIBILITY OF ELECTRONIC DEBIT
CARDS.
THE KIND OF THINGS WE ARE TO
USE, THE VA AND THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
MIGHT MAKE IT EASIER FOR THOSE
WHO DON’T HAVE BANK ACCOUNTS AND
ARE IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED BY FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO GET THE MONEY
THEY NEED TO BUY THE GROCERIES
OR PAY THE BILLS.
IT’S JUST ONE POSSIBILITY THAT
WE THINK TREASURY SHOULD EXPLORE
TO MAKE SURE THAT DISTRESSED
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
GETTING THE RELIEF THEY NEED IN
A TIMELY FASHION.
>> Ed: THAT’S IMPORTANT ON THE
INDIVIDUAL SIDE AND AS YOU NOTED
THERE IS THE SMALL BUSINESS
SIDE.
A LOT OF FOLKS VERY HARD HIT.
SENATOR McCONNELL IS EXPECTED
TO SPEAK EARLY ABOUT THIS